[Music]
this week we've got bad suggestion freak
accidents and agoraphobic traveler
take it away Tiffany for a first story
the man behind the passwords
requirements so he has now said in an
interview that she regrets the
guidelines that he placed which means
that you know how we had to have a
capital lies letter in the past number
number a special symbol a special
character yeah why does my password
gotta look like my screen name from AOL
days lowercase a so now he's saying that
he regrets hearing that advice back in
2003
why so what people do now because of
these requirements the O's turn into
zeros the at or the A's turn into the @
sign oh I could just figure it out so it
doesn't really like you could literally
write out password but with different
symbols symbols and letters or numbers
and so you're just saying we got how
lazy humans are they're going to terrify
the simplest way is a nice way to put it
or maybe forgetful yeah I could be
saying that people can't remember
complicated passwords I get to get a
password generator then yeah that's good
but you're not going to remember your
password so I got like 20 password me
too
every single thing is a different I try
to make my [ __ ] as [ __ ] easy as
possible to me oh it's no he doesn't
it's very complicated all of the factors
are very complex twenty characters is so
stupid I have one one password for
everything no he doesn't he doesn't like
Joe Mallya one but yeah it all you're
just gonna be aa [ __ ] now I got to
change it tomorrow to this yeah 0:01 I
try to be good all my past-due I try
using those I generated ones and then
I'll keep it all in the notebook that I
have written that homework you're
responsible it's really smart
yeah I don't like to say it's like
what's the hack your computer and they
get it in your note they can't hack my
notebook that's because the pillows here
no [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't miss anybody
oh you do located on
okay it is to your house but we actually
do now so 10 yet so I keep my password
protected as best as I can but then
every time I hear like that we get
hacked like that whole thing where as
Jay King Network got hacked oh my god
change all the passwords that's what I
found out so I was talking to a grey hat
hacker and your passwords actually don't
yeah it doesn't mean injection because
they're hacking at a way higher level to
hacking the server server once they get
to the server they can get to 50,000
accounts the person that was talking to
you who had our did hack studio 71 our
networks server and through that they
were able to get you when your twitter
yeah no I think I was like gee I just
see you know like someone's tweeting
stuff they do that they hacked our
Twitter our Amazon account our PayPal
like everything so it's like these
little passwords at this like bottom
level it doesn't matter at all what do
they even do it like with you guys what
did they do with the account well their
gray hat so they didn't do anything
those are showing that they can
infiltrate this and then the ties are
served by their service so that happen
is why they're not malicious they're
just letting you know look how easy it
is for me to break into your house
selection or like your [ __ ] is weak yeah
and then once you go you see its weak I
was able to hack it now this is the anti
hack glass is safe and we just became
friends so your passwords don't do jack
[ __ ] oh you became friends with your
hackers I actually like them like I like
people that tell me you know like I
would like to know if I had a
vulnerability like hey just to let you
know your front doors unlocked I went
inside and fed your dog very nice I like
smelly scratch like you come home as
with guy laid in the bathtub that's
original easy to come in here literally
at all your back door wide open man next
time I could have been a rapist
it's like thanks dude it's kind of scary
how everything we depend on right now is
online at like our entire livelihood
like lives with everything is online
yeah like scary there's like nothing
manual about our jobs
you know everything literally involves a
login and a password which is very scary
exactly take it away sofa I mean you
can't take money to the grave and if the
apocalypse happens like money doesn't
really matter so what I have
is a bunch of gold and cans of tuna and
guns while you are literally cat you
have a bunch of cans of tuna - yeah well
that's pretty smart dish - you both are
gonna get hot so fast huh
so we're gonna break it to your house
your tuna collection is going to be done
you're gonna look like not the gold yeah
I gotta keep the gold there she has a
vault though because uh there's no way
you can get you can't get my two notes
in the bolts oh just wait but the guns
are outside it's portable
I have but if [ __ ] goes down
preparedness and then I have like normal
life I bet you you don't I have three
travel toiletry bags in my car Dan extra
clothes Oh ignited my car I got to put
in my car I have extra clothes
everything I'm a Kinect legs I'm
unprepared like a mama I'm the type of
person where like I'll keep stuff in my
backpack just in case like if I have a
water bottle that I'm no I'm not going
to drink from like on this hold on to it
just in case there's like this much
water I'm like you just never know when
you're going to need that water exactly
back right now
what if somehow I'm driving my car flips
over and I end up what's that book the
hatchet I don't really read in school
you had to read the hatchet my team okay
well that will not steps whatever though
anyway the boy ends up lost in the
forest for years and he I wanted to read
it but never mind
that's our toil sorry about that it's
like what if I end up like the boy
matches right there did you have this
much water and like a brother yes I
think completely different I think like
a criminal so I always good I don't need
[ __ ] cuz if I need something I'm just
going to drive my car through a 7-eleven
rate that [ __ ] and pull my car
out that's probably why you're not
reading this yeah oh we need guns and
tuna
why what a pirate need to be prepared
but you know what I don't have a can
opener someone by the hair and slam them
against the can of tuna Megumi would you
usually go into that house and there's a
father and it was 7-eleven okay seven
alarm Epirus he's in 7-eleven with his
little daughter and they've been
surviving off of this Max and they're on
their last food you're still going to
steal it from them he probably would
also know okay transverses well
okay they're like three crackers you're
going to take your three crackers out
the little girl's hand and be like wrong
feminine I'm going to rock is up at
eleven not worry about the best wrong
bar you need to enslave them wash them
alive so they can work for you true good
where's your morals now bill the college
that's what all game alright next story
there's this mom with his two kids that
were stuck on a car that was face right
up like the car popped the wheel on a
car in a car in a car oh [ __ ] so were
they like in a roller coaster like this
pretty much that's crazy
do they do the flip bottle with a car
why didn't they just get out so what
happened was the mom was driving a
Melvin lightning storm also they drove
past this telephone pole that had
collapsed and so she didn't notice that
so it she drove past it somehow the car
got stuck and then the pole went back up
oh yeah you know the car ended up face
up Bhagyam I immediately called 911 she
was saying like she called Domino's
[ __ ] soft to explaining a situation and
the 9-1-1 operator just a really common
collector Oded and he was just like okay
you know just calm down stay home for
your kids she's like I don't know what
to do sure yeah the car you guys know
stay in the vehicle I would have died I
would expect I don't even know how to
explain a situation like that like hey
I'm [ __ ] hanging from a car there's
some wires like what man please calm
down what's going on so I was driving
right and just [ __ ] booby-trapped
looking awful ah yeah you're just like
make sure the windows are up like don't
worry is because of their life cords
yeah oh my god any news about that like
like am I going to get electrocuted I
think and he's like no here you're going
to be fine should I turn the car on or
off which I mean hearing his answer
here's how I know you're going to be
fine oh yeah Oh God did you like what no
no you're good why didn't she just go
through the backseat crawl through the
trunk because of the live wires
yeah and then also like he was telling
her and they don't move
fake long don't get out you're just
raining - I give you an electric to
dirty up I want to dive in for
I thank God nine-one-one is my last
resort
yes I crawled out through the trunk and
then I'll move sometimes what I saw not
true is if I'm if I'm not hurt and I'm
just in that position was it back
downer frontier like that's that yeah it
sounds like this right I'll take off my
feet though crawl out and imagine being
stuck like making downwards how long
were they in there for until everyone
came for about 30 minutes I'm back that
would scare me
so it was her five and four year old Oh
No yeah so this is when it crying the
whole time or were they like we yeah I'm
starving and angry at the same time
they're like twin they do look like how
cute they are they're super cute it's
their eyes and smile yes a moment and
everything they're little angels I would
have never posed like that in a picture
why I hated pictures like that like I
thought it was a stock photo for a
minute look at professionals like I
thought I'm not that good
that's what coffee box corner to you try
to show you like the girl that you like
you know oh you want a hug your sister
up like that that's not on Kozma you're
going to get no kindergarten [ __ ] like
that on a bit power already kindergarten
I want to give you [ __ ] because they
have cooties
yeah gerb do big group senior adult
little ding-dong
you are better perverse in kindergarten
I know you married him yeah maybe you're
not having a baby risen I'm also a
pervert perverts
have it this family when they were
getting interviewed they actually met up
with the phone operator and they gave
him a hug and they were just really
happy and then like the fire department
they went over with cupcakes oh love you
small courses like rushing over there
like shop we have to get cupcakes they
can do another ten minutes in the car
brings them the cupcake yes this is
place in Connecticut small town in
Connecticut I love small towns but I
hate them Connecticut scares me because
everyone's gonna like the scary movies
they're always based in Connecticut are
they all really were in Connecticut it's
okay it's only for white people
there's always that get off true because
we're not in the movies so oh yeah no
we're no III think oh wait is no one to
leave we're like yeah Sunday I'm going
to go we're gonna bruja okay so for our
last story there's this awesome chorus
Bobeck artists who travel the world via
Google Streetview I mean you're scared
of travel culture a golden screw you
culture [ __ ] is a culture fear fear of
public places public transportation and
open spaces or large crowds yes isn't
that freakin Omar exactly as I was just
like alright we just got into an
argument about traveling so yeah that's
actually he's going to hold it yes he's
not he just hates being in an airplane
he's not afraid of them he's just like I
don't want to terrible like what we're
going to Japan and he's like I don't
know expose expose he doesn't like
expose yeah you're wrong you know what
is yeah I don't think he likes people
well I like Omar almost though you like
you guys I was awesome
but like a big random crowd of strangers
he's like no but it only back there is a
big crowd of friends he's cool yeah
so counter to his industry I know this
what if you have to talk to like 6,000
people about bodybuilding you like he
would do it but if they were surrounding
him he'd be like all right buddy just
take it back so he doesn't do
meet-and-greet
yeah actually right in his industry
because all he intended to do was give
information via a [ __ ] yeah yeah the
end right yeah he was like like he
recently held that meetup when he hit
500,000 and he rented out a movie
theater he did great
but I think it was like a controlled
environment everyone knows him and she
doesn't it's not strangers no they were
all strangers we just invited them to
the movie theater and he screamed like
alien vs. predator or something like
that and what I saw was the scene where
before there's--like died be like it's
aliens I don't know but it sounds very
all mine but he made sure that him and I
were pretty much in our own aisles and
then everybody else was around white
pants with Doc Martens no he wore black
pants with Doc Martin I remember Josh
Martin's are like the only nice pair of
shoes he owned heel toe toe and with
this a woman name is Jackie she's from
London and so usually agoraphobic they
tend to only stay in their home because
they're just so afraid of going out in
public so she has extreme anxiety and
panic attacks she's been dealing with
this for the past 20 years but she wants
to travel though what is she scared of
it's just like they just have a fear of
germs or like something like a freak
accident have you ever watched shameless
no okay and shameless one of the one of
the characters a mob is agoraphobic and
like she has she would have a stepper
and she'd count how many steps she could
do that day because like she would open
the door and the sounds they would like
raise the volume on the sounds like
everything sounds too loud
people's chatter just seems to close by
so imagine like if somebody came up to
me with yelling in your face that's how
they feel when a stranger just talks to
them it just freaks them out they're
hypersensitive to the world yeah so
everything is like times 100
exactly well I do too just best people
didn't hit it fun come on she's scared
Jackie was really struggling with
everything around her because the
company that she had fell apart she's
agoraphobic but then she had a whole
company that she was running yeah I mean
she was not that severe way like she
just she can't leave her house like she
does leave her husband even mentioned
that she'll go to a supermarket but she
can't go to the aisles in the back of
the stores and she'll feel expensive
stuff it affects people differently so
that's the way it affects her and so
when she came across Google Streetview
she was actually kind of a little bit
worried she's like I don't know if this
is healthy spending hours and hours and
hours on and like just traveling the
world
it sounds healthy but then yeah she
realized that it was actually helping
her a lot because at one point she
wanted to be a photographer and through
this experience of viewing the world
through Google Streetview shoot she's
been taking spills and she has an
Instagram account where she uploads the
spills and this is like kind of like her
art this is my snail in the backyard
because like the hills of the Google map
Google sheet oh yeah over here some of
her photos what I had even hard photos
dude that's like war-torn Afghanistan
what the [ __ ] is that
yeah I don't know where these places are
oh this is like Alaska but you know when
I saw this I immediately related to her
because back of the day before I met you
guys and
I was I had a lot of downtime and I was
bored a lot I would actually do this too
I would travel the world via Google
Streetview and a really exciting because
I would be like oh when I visit Paris I
wanna do that that's like and I'll like
go because you can actually go in yeah
it's like a 360 view of your world
stalker and then like you could click
the arrow to go forward or back or a
street or whatever and I'd be like
walking the streets of Paris that filled
my little computer I try to spy on North
Korea that way I think that yeah I guess
it is active is cool I shouldn't do that
in Vice City but never like other
countries no I started off with my city
and I realized that on APLA map they
have this like 3d tour where like on my
phone I discovered it on my phone now
you click on it and it gives you like
Illig zoom in to like certain landscapes
as well nobody and then when I was in
Bekaa I don't do that and I'm like cool
and that's when I was like when I can
also see the mirror and then that's how
I would start exploring the world I try
to spy on North Korea like that and area
51 but then they didn't let me they
block out certain places yeah she has an
entire Instagram account there's
agoraphobia oh hi there always people in
this shots like it's places where you
wouldn't expect anyone to be there's
always someone standing there yeah she
says it has its downsides though about
90% of the time she has to adjust to
experience the disappointment because
she'll see something out in the distance
and she can't go out and see oh yeah
she's I call you know I have to prepare
myself for that disappointment because I
can't see everything is it inspiring her
to want to go out there and see these
stones know how that looks like a
playground I would love this is on top
of it and let me play guys its massive
and then I could be around the world is
a mysterious place looking at this - it
would be really cool like in the future
if you can actually like live travel
there through like a VR thing totally
like you can visit people and be really
cool technology that would be actually
there you know what's all I watched a
lot of documentaries about like friends
and stuff like that and I was like I
already sent it but then when I went
there for your weddings and we were
walking around Versailles and everything
I was like
oh I'm different it's kind of like
looking at a skill of Grand Canyon
versus being there yeah I'm just like oh
my goodness someone made this
yeah and it's a different emotional
experience yeah one is like a logical
like I'm learning about it this is
awesome and then the other one is just
like oh wow this is crazy
yeah I guess for people that suffer like
the agoraphobia and they just can't make
it out there how to any spaces this is a
really cool alternative
it might even inspire them to want to
like get out a little bit and it's not
for her somebody else is agoraphobic you
know I might try that and then it just
could they never probably thought of
that yeah hey you guys want to stock any
of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]